TODAY, SPEED ROUND IS BROUGHT
TO YOU BY VERIZON AND LET'S
GET TO IT. THE CHRIS SIMMS
MOCK DRAFT FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF HOW SOME OF
THESE PICS MIGHT BE RECEIVED
CHRIS AND LET'S START AT
SELECTION. NUMBER 12, THE
EAGLES TRADED DOWN FROM SIX
QUARTERBACK. JASON SEHORN, I
THINK PETER KING HAS THE SAME
GOD GOING TO EAGLES. LOT OF,
WELL, DO WORD ASSOCIATION,
WHAT IS THE EAGLES FAN
REACTION? IF THAT HAPPENS, I
THINK THEY'RE GOING TO BE
BE LIKE, MAN. LOOK AT THIS
GUY, THIS BIG PHYSICAL FREE
CORNER, WE NEED HELP THERE.
YOU KNOW, THAT WAS ONE, WHERE
LISTEN, I DON'T LOVE JC HORN,
THE PLAYER I DON'T, BUT
THERE'S JUST TOO MANY PEOPLE
THAT GOT HIM LINKED TO THE
PHILADELPHIA EAGLES AND FOR
THEM FOR GET AGAIN, THEY'RE
GOING TO RUN A SEATTLE TYPE
OF SCHEME A LITTLE BIT. HE
FITS THAT AS FAR AS THE MOLD
OF THAT TYPE OF CORNER
RATHER THAN ONE THAT'S GOING
TO LOCK DOWN PEOPLE
ONE-ON-ONE. SO, YOU KNOW,
FANS. EVERYBODY THINKS THE
SAME. HE'S AWESOME. I'M IN.
THE MINORITY HERE. I THINK
THERE'S GOING TO BE A GOOD
REACTION WITH IT. FIRST OF
ALL, I DON'T THINK, EAGLES
FANS AND HAPPY. I DON'T THINK
THAT THIS RIGHT NOW, RIGHT?
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO BE HAPPY
UNTIL THEY GET ANOTHER SUPER
BOWL BECAUSE THEY GOT A TASTE
OF ONE AND THEY WANT MORE,
AND THEY WANT THEM NOW. AND I
I THINK THAT I THINK THAT
THEY'LL BE LIKE, OKAY. ALL
RIGHT, THAT'S THAT'S WHAT
EVERYONE'S EXPECTING. YEAH,
LET'S SEE IF THE GUY CAN PLAY
AND LET'S SEE IF WE CAN
ADDRESS SOME OF THESE MANY
OTHER NEEDS. WE HAVE LATER IN
THE DRAFT, I THINK THE
ASTUTE EAGLES FAN WOULD BE
HOPE.
FOR A TRADE DOWN AND MORE
PICS BECAUSE THEY HAVE SO
MANY NEEDS TO ADDRESS. THE
BIG THING IS MIKE, LIKE,
WHO'S THE TRADE UP FOR?
THAT'S THE THING. I THINK
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET INTO
THIS LIKE A LOT OF TEAMS ARE
GOING TO LOOK TO TRADE DOWN,
BUT WE KNOW THERE'S LACK OF
MARQUE SUPERSTAR PLAYERS AND
THIS DRAFT. SO I DON'T ONCE
YOU GET PAST 10:00, I DON'T
KNOW WHO EVERYONE'S TRADING
UP FOR, IT'S LIKE A NICE TALK
AND THOUGHT AND EVERYTHING
LIKE THAT, BUT IT'S A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF PLAYERS. I THINK
THAT'S KIND OF ONE OF THE
THINGS I'M INTERESTED TO SEE
YOU KNOW THURSDAY NIGHT
RIGHT? WELL ON PETER, KING'S
DEVANTE SMITH. THE HEISMAN
TROPHY WINNER MAKES IT ALL
THE WAY TO 15 AND WE TALKED
YESTERDAY THAT 10 TO 10 TO 15
RANGE WOULD BE THE SWEET
SPOT. FOR SOMEBODY WHO LOVES
HIM RICE, AM GOING TO GO GET
HIM THAT OPENS THE DOOR. YEAH,
A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT TO
TRADE DOWN. YOU GOT TO FIND A
TEAM THAT IS IN LOVE WITH A
PROSPECT THAT THINKS HE'S
GOING TO BE A HUGE DIFFERENCE
MAKER AND THAT SEES HIM SLIDE
INTO STRIKING DISTANCE AND
THEY MOBILIZE JUST LIKE THAT
GO. GET IT. YOU'RE RIGHT
AREN'T GOING TO HAPPEN
BECAUSE EVERYONE IS TRADING
UP FOR A SPECIFIC, RIGHT
PLAYER. WHEN THE TRADE UP
HAPPENS DURING THE DRAFT, ALL
WHAT WILL MY REACTION BE
IF THE VIKINGS TAKE USC'S?
ELIJAH VEERA TUCKER AT NUMBER
14? WELL, WHO WRITES THESE
? YOUR BEST FRIEND? MATT
CASEY THAT'S ALSO WHAT'S
WHAT'S YOUR VIKING? WHAT'S
VIKING, SUPERFAN FLORIO.
CALL OFFENSE OR LINE THERE.
FIRST OF ALL, I AM NOT A
SUPERFAN BOULOGNE BY HATE. I
HATE ALL TEAMS EQUALLY AND I
HATE YOU EVEN MORE. HEY, YOU
KNOW, THE THING ABOUT THE
EVERYONE WANTS THE SEXY
SKILL POSITION FANTASY
FOOTBALL, PICK THE GUY WHOSE
JERSEY, YOU'RE GOING TO WANT
TO BUY, NO ONE'S GOING TO
WANT TO BUY AN OFFENSIVE,
LINEMAN'S JERSEY. BUT YOU
NEED, AS I SAID YESTERDAY,
INFRASTRUCTURE TO LET THE
OTHER GUYS OPERATE.
DOZENS NEEDS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. THEY GOT RID
OF RILEY REEF. I DON'T KNOW
THAT EZRA CLEVELAND'S THE
ANSWER AT LEFT TACKLE AND YOU
NEED THE GUY THAT CAN DO THE
THE KUBIAK, THEY TRADED ONE
KUBIAK FOR THE OTHER. CLINT
GOING TO BE RUNNING THE
OFFENSE, RIGHT? SAME SCHEME.
NEED SOMEBODY WHO CAN COME IN
AND HELP THAT OFFENSIVE LINE
BE BETTER. AND THAT'S WHERE
THE VIKINGS HAVE FOCUSED IN
THE FIRST ROUND. YEAH. IN
RECENT YEARS. THEY AND SECOND
ROUND THERE. TRY TO MAKE THAT
OFFENSIVE LINE BETTER BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE A PATRICK
MAHOMES WHO CAN RUN AROUND
ALL DAY LONG AND BY TIME THE
OFFENSE,
OF LINE BUYS THE TIME FOR
THEIR QUARTERBACK. YEAH NO
DOUBT I MEAN THE GET THE WAY
THEY PLAY IS IT SET UP BY
THEIR OFFENSIVE LINE IN THE
ABILITY TO OPEN UP HOLES FROM
DALVIN COOK. THAT'S REALLY
THAT'S THE JUMP OFF POINT
FOR EVERYTHING ELSE ON THEIR
OFFENSE. EVERYTHING ELSE IN
THEIR OFFICE DOESN'T WORK SO
WELL, REALLY WHEN THEY CAN'T
DO THAT. SO VERA, TUCKER, YOU
KNOW, CAN BE, I THINK IS A
LEFT TACKLE AND CAN PLAY LEFT
TACKLE, BUT AT THE VERY WORST,
HE'S GOING TO BE A REALLY
AWESOME GUARD FOR A LONG TIME.
SO I DON'T THINK THERE'S
LIKE YOU CAN'T MISS WITH HIM
IN MY OPINION AS FAR AS WHAT
HE CAN.
FOR THE VIKINGS OFFENSE LINE.
BUT LIKE, WELL, LET ME ASK
YOU THIS MIC. JUST AS A, THE
SUPERFAN THAT YOU ARE OF THE
VIKINGS, WILL YOU SHUT UP?
BUT YOU WOULD YOU BE MAD
THOUGH? IF LIKE, YOU KNOW,
JALEN PHILLIPS, QUIT IPE,
LIKE THOSE TYPE OF GUYS EDGE
PASS RUSHERS. WOULD YOU
RATHER HAVE THAT ON YOUR
FOOTBALL TEAM RIGHT NOW THAN
THE OFFENSIVE LINE? I THINK
THE VIKINGS HAVE A GREATER
NEED RIGHT NOW, IT PASS
RUSHER THAN THEY DO IT
OFFENSIVE LINE. ALTHOUGH
THEY'VE GOT SO MUCH INVESTED
IN KIRK COUSINS.
SALARY NEXT YEAR. THEY'VE GOT
TO MAKE THAT WORK PERIOD. SO
I THINK THAT'S THE WAY IT'S
GOING TO GO AND THEN THEY'LL
TRY TO FIND PASS RUSHERS
LATER IN THE DRAFT.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT IT IS
A GREATER NEED RIGHT NOW. ALL
RIGHT, GIANTS, FAN REACTION.
IF GAY. IF DAVE GET THEM IN
THE GM OF THE TEAM WHO NEVER
TRADES DOWN THE GIANTS,
HAVEN'T TRADED DOWN SINCE
2006. WHAT'S THEIR REACTION?
IF THEY TRADE BACK AND GET
THE PENN STATE EDGE? RUSHER
JASON. OH UH, I MEAN, I'M A
BIG FAN OF JASON, I THINK.
IT'S, I THINK IT'S A WAY I
BELIEVE. OH WHEY. OH I KNOW
YOU WILL GET IT WHEN HE GETS
LOTS OF SOCKS IN THE NFL. I'M
A HUGE FAN OF THIS PLAYER.
NOW, THE BIG THING IS MIKE,
IS HE DIDN'T GET A LOT OF
SACKS SACKS. AREN'T THAT EASY
IN COLLEGE FOOTBALL, FIRST
OFF? I MEAN, IT'S OUR POS,
IT'S READ OPTION AT SCREEN
AND SCREEN AND SCREEN. I MEAN,
YOU COULD GO 15 DROP BACK
PASSES WHERE THE QUARTERBACK
DOESN'T REALLY DROP BACK TO
LET A PASS RUSH GET TO HIM.
SO THAT'S WHERE I THINK
GET TO HIM. SO THAT'S WHERE I
THINK THAT'S MISLEADING AND
FOR ME.
AGAIN, HE MIGHT NOT BE MY
FAVORITE PASS, RUSHER ON THE
DROP, BUT HE'S A FREAK OF
NATURE. THERE'S TRUE EDGE
NEED THEREFORE THE NEW YORK
FOOTBALL, GIANTS. AND AND
I JUST BELIEVE IT'S THE TYPE
OF PLAYER THAT THE GIANTS AND
THE PATRIOTS WOULD BELIEVE IN
TO BE AN EDGE GUY. THEY
BELIEVE IN LENGTH WHEN IT
COMES TO THOSE EDGE GUYS,
ESPECIALLY IN THE NEW
ENGLAND, JOE JUDGE, PATRICK
GRAHAM. SO, THAT'S WHERE I
DON'T THINK EQUITY PAY, IS
TYPE OF PLAYER ON THE EDGE. I
NO, A WHO'S MORE OF LIKE A
LEONARD, FLOYD WHO AGAIN, NOT
A SACK MASTER, BUT I'D TAKEN
LEONARD FLOYD ON MY TEAM. ANY
DAY OF THE WEEK, HE'S ONE OF
THE BEST EDGE DEFENDERS AND
FOOTBALL. AND I THINK, I'LL
CAN BE A LOT LIKE HIM. YEAH.
AND AND HEY WHEN THE GIANTS
HAVE BEEN REALLY GOOD IN
RECENT YEARS, I'VE SAID THIS
TIME AND AGAIN GREAT
OFFENSIVE LINE, GREAT DEFENSE.
YEAH, IT'S EASY TO GET
CAUGHT UP IN THE SCOPE
POSITION PLAYERS, BUT IT'S
THE LINE ON BOTH SIDES THAT
MAKE A TEAM GREAT. YOU CAN
HAVE PLENTY AND THERE ARE
PLENTY OF GREAT SKILL
POSITION PLAYERS THROUGHOUT
THE LEAGUE AND THEY WILL.
AND YOU TO BE THE DIFFERENCE
IS GOING TO COME FROM HOW
WELL, YOU CAN BLOCK ON
OFFENSE AND HOW MUCH CHAOS
YOU CAN CREATE ON DEFENSE FOR
THOSE GREAT SKILL POSITION
PLAYERS. WHAT WILL AARON
RODGERS REACTION BE IF AS
YOU'VE PROJECTED, THE PACKERS
TAKE FLORIDA, RECEIVER COULD
AREA STONY AT NUMBER 29. YEAH
YOU KNOW I MEAN I WOULD HOPE
HE'D BE REALLY DAMN HAPPY.
AND I MEAN AGAIN THIS IS I
THINK A NEED FOR THIS
FOOTBALL TEAM, ANOTHER
PLAYMAKER ON THE OFFENSIVE
SIDE OF THE FOOTBALL.
ONLY, I MEAN, COULD THEY BE
IN THE MIDDLE LINEBACKER
CONVERSATION? MAYBE IF
THERE'S ONE THERE BUT I THINK
REALLY ALL THE FIRST ROUND
LINEBACKERS ARE GOING TO BE
OFF THE BOARD BY THE TIME
THEY PICK YOU KNOW. SO THAT'S
WHERE YOU KNOW I CAME AWAY
WITH GREEN BAY GOING. ALRIGHT
YEAH I KNOW THEY COULD MAYBE
USE AN OFFENSIVE LINEMAN I'M
NOT SURE IF THERE'S IT'S THAT
DESPERATE AND TONY IS LIKE I
DON'T HE'S TYREKE ILISH. YOU
KNOW, HE'S NOT QUITE AS FAST
AS TYREE KILLED. NO HUMAN IS
BUT IT'S THAT TYPE OF PLAYER.
ARE YOU KNOW, I THINK GREEN
BAY COULD USE HIM AS THEIR
THEIR DEBO SAMUEL WRIGHT AND
THE 49ERS SYSTEM, THE SPEED
SWEEPS, THE TOSS REVERSES,
THE THE OCCASIONAL ACTUAL
SWEEP AND HAVE PEOPLE
BLOCKING THEM THAT WAY. HEY
PLAY ACTION PASS. OH BACK
SIDE SLAM DUNKED ERICA
DARIO'S TONY, HE'S
ONE-ON-ONE. OH MAN, HE'S
RUNNING LIKE HIS HAIR'S ON
FIRE THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF
THE DEFENSE. THAT'S THE KIND
GUY HE IS. HE'S A WEAPON WHO
COULD USE A LITTLE MORE
POLISH OF RECEIVER, BUT HE'S
TOO FREAKY FOR ME TO THINK HE
GETS OUT OF THE FIRST ROUND.
GREEN BAY TAKING. HE BETTER
BE HAPPY. I HOPE SO WOULD
ROGERS RATHER HAVE YOUR GUY
FROM NORTH CAROLINA, DES AMIS
BROWN-EYED. THAT'S, THAT'S
LIKE, I LOVE THE AMI BROWN
AND I LIKE HIM MORE THAN
COULD AREAS. TONY, THE ONLY
I WOULD SAY IS, YOU KNOW,
HE'S A LITTLE BIT. THEY HAVE
A MARQUEZ VALDEZ SCANTLING
WHO IS THAT DEEP GUY, TAKE
THE TOP, OFF THE DEFENSE SO I
JUST WONDERED. HEY, YEAH,
HE'S NOT AS GOOD AS THE AMI
BROWN, BUT MY LOGIC WAS LIKE,
THEY NEED TO FIND A
DIFFERENT TYPE OF GUY TO
OUT. YOU KNOW, THEY'RE
RECEIVING CORPS. THAT WAS
LOGIC THERE, BUT I LOVE ME
SOME D AMI BROWN AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S FAR-FETCHED TO
THINK HE DOES. SQUEEZE HIM AT
THE END OF THE FIRST ROUND. I
JUST CAN'T HELP, BUT WONDER
WHETHER THE PACKERS WITH
THOSE RECEIVERS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE THERE JUST LIKE
LAST YEAR, YOU KNOW, YOU
CRANK THE FINGER ON AARON
RODGERS AS YOU CONTINUE THIS
AWKWARD TUG-OF-WAR AND BACK
AND FORTH LAST YEAR. THEY
DIDN'T DRAFT A SINGLE
RECEIVER. SO WE'LL SEE IF
THEY GET SOMEBODY EITHER TO
HELP AARON RODGERS. NOW OR
IS AROUND IN, JUST TWO DAYS.
LET'S TAKE A BREAK. WHEN WE
RETURN A DRAFT FOCUSED ON THE
WAR ROOMS THAT WE MOST LIKE
TO BE IN THIS YEAR FOR THE
DRAFT WILL DO THAT WHEN PFT
LIVE CONTINUES RIGHT AFTER
THIS.
PRO FOOTBALL TALK IS BROUGHT
TO YOU BY VERIZON BUILT RIGHT
FOR BUSINESS.